good to see you again facing an
increasingly tense standoff over ukraine
u.s president joe biden and russian
president vladimir putin spent two hours
engaged in intense talks he told
president putin directly that if russia
further invades ukraine the united
states and our european allies would
respond with strong economic measures
we would provide additional defensive
materiel to the ukrainians and we would
fortify our nato allies on the eastern
flank with additional capabilities in
recent weeks russia has amassed an
estimated 100 000 troops near the
ukraine border along with tanks and
artillery u.s intelligence believes
putin could be preparing to launch a
full-blown invasion as early as january
this build-up is concerning to us it is
still not
entirely clear what mr putin's
intentions are the issue is ukraine's
place in the world
russia wants assurances that the former
soviet state will not be allowed to join
nato or even cooperate with the western
alliance
the u.s has refused to accept such
demands biden says he fully supports
ukraine's sovereignty i'm not sure putin
really wants it part of russia so much
as he just doesn't want it part of the
west on top of promising additional
military aid the u.s has warned any
invasion would trigger severe economic
sanctions against russia moscow could be
cut off from the global financial system
but that has not deterred putin in the
past and some experts believe the
military buildup is simply a ploy
designed to make cooperation between
ukraine and the west seem too risky it
makes ukrainians perhaps want to join
nato more but i think it makes other
nato countries want to invite ukraine in
less
because we realize what that would mean
it would mean the possibility of war
against russia though neither leader
seemed to budge in their position the
white house did describe the
conversation as direct and
straightforward a sign perhaps that
diplomacy may be an achievable path to
warding off conflict
jackson prosko global news washington